Back in the introduction, we spoke
a little about the various programming
models that you'll use when
building Android applications.
And in particular,
using Services to build them.
One pattern that is
available to developers for
a synchronous programming in Android
is when you use an IntentService.
When using these, clients send requests
through a method called StartService.
And if needed,
the service then starts and
it handles each intent in
turn using a worker thread.
It captures all of these in
the onHandleIntent override and
when it runs out of work,
it will simply stop itself.
This design pattern is commonly
called a work queue processor and
it's often used to offload tasks
from an application's main thread.
We'll be using one in this sample but
I won't go into depth on how it works,
just on how we can use it for
our own needs.
If you're interested on how
it works on a deeper level,
take a look at the resources
in the instructor notes below.
Let's get started.